Pourtant ce sont des décisions que des IA ont prises très récemment,
basées sur les biais qu'elle a appris de nous,
des humains.
L'IA est utilisée pour décider de si vous obtenez cet entretien d'embauche,
de combien vous payez votre assurance auto,
de votre cote de solvabilité,
et même de l'appréciation de votre performance annuelle.
Mais ces décisions sont prises en faisant
des hypothèses basées sur notre nom, notre ethnie, notre sexe et notre âge.
Comment ça se passe?
Prenez une IA aidant un DRH
à trouver le prochain leader high-tech de la société.
Jusqu'à présent, le gérant n'a embauché que des hommes.
L'IA apprend donc que les hommes sont plus souvent programmeurs que les femmes.
Et de là il n'y a qu'un pas vers :
« Les hommes programment mieux que les femmes. »
Nous avons introduit nos propres biais dans l'IA.
Et ensuite, elle élimine les candidats féminins.
Si un DRH humain faisait ça,
nous serions scandalisés, ça ne passerait pas.
Les discriminations sexistes ne sont pas acceptables.
Et pourtant, l'IA est au-dessus des lois,
parce que la décision est prise par une machine.
Ce n'est pas tout.
Nous renforçons également nos biais à travers notre interaction avec l'IA.
Combien de fois avez-vous utilisé un assistant vocal comme Siri ou Alexa ?
Ils ont tous deux choses en commun :
ils ne prononcent jamais correctement mon nom,
et deuxièmement, ce sont tous des femmes.
Ils ont été créés pour être d'obéissants serviteurs,
allumant et éteignant la lumière, passant des commandes.
Il y a aussi des IA homme mais ils ont généralement plus de pouvoirs,
par exemple, IBM Watson qui prend des décisions commerciales,
Salesforce Einstein ou ROSS, le robot avocat.
Ainsi, même ces pauvres robots souffrent du sexisme dans le milieu du travail.
(Rires)
Pensez à comment ces deux points combinés
affectent un enfant grandissant dans un monde baignant dans l'IA.
Imaginez qu'il fasse une recherche pour un projet à l'école
et qu'il tape sur Google, « images de PDG ».
L'algorithme ne lui montre que des hommes.
Ensuite, il tape « assistant personnel ».
Comme vous pouvez l'imaginez, il n'y a pratiquement que des femmes.
Ensuite, il veut mettre de la musique ou commander à manger,
et pour cela il aboie des ordres à une obéissante voix féminine.
Ces technologies sont créées par certains de nos plus brillants cerveaux.
Ils pouvaient créer ces technologies exactement comme ils le souhaitaient.
Et ils ont choisi de les créer dans le style secrétaire des « Mad Men ».
Super !
Ne vous inquiétez pas,
je ne vais pas finir en vous disant que
nous allons vers un monde dirigé par des machines sexistes et racistes.
La bonne nouvelle est que les IA sont entièrement sous notre contrôle.
Nous pouvons leur enseigner les bonnes valeurs, l'éthique.
Il y a trois choses que nous pouvons faire.
Premièrement, nous pouvons avoir conscience de nos propres biais
et des biais des machines qui nous entourent.
Ensuite, nous pouvons nous assurer que des équipes mixtes construisent les IA.
Et enfin, les IA doivent apprendre à partir d'expériences variées.
Je peux parler des deux premiers points par expérience personnelle.
Quand vous travaillez dans la technologie
sans ressembler à Mark Zuckerberg ou Elon Musk,
votre vie est un peu difficile, vos compétences sont remises en question.
Voici un exemple.
Comme la plupart des programmeurs, je participe sur des forums tech en ligne
et partage mes connaissances pour aider les autres.
Et j'ai découvert
qu'en me connectant avec ma vraie photo et mon vrai nom,
j'ai tendance à recevoir des questions ou commentaires comme ceux-ci :
« Tu crois être qualifiée pour parler d'IA ? »
« Qu'est-ce qui te fait penser que tu t'y connais en machine learning ? »
Je me suis donc créé un nouveau profil,
avec à la place de ma photo, un chat avec un jet pack.
J'ai choisi un nom qui ne révélait pas mon genre.
Vous voyez où je veux en venir, non ?
Cette foi, je n'ai reçu aucun commentaire condescendant sur mes capacités
et je pouvais travailler correctement.
Ça craint, les gars.
Je construis des robots depuis mes 15 ans,
j'ai plusieurs diplômes en informatique,
et pourtant, je dois cacher mon genre
pour que mon travail soit pris au sérieux.
Que se passe-t-il ?
Les hommes sont-ils juste meilleurs que les femmes en technologie ?
Une autre étude a trouvé
que quand les codeurs femmes cachaient, comme moi, leur genre sur une plateforme,
leur code était accepté 4% de plus que celui des hommes.
Donc ce n'est pas un problème de talent.
C'est un problème d'élitisme dans l'IA qui dit
qu'un développeur doit ressembler à une certaine personne.
Ce que nous devons faire pour rendre l'IA meilleure,
c'est rassembler des gens de toutes origines.
Nous avons besoin de gens pouvant écrire des histoires
pour créer des personnalités aux IA,
pouvant résoudre des problèmes,
pouvant faire face à différents défis
et de personnes pouvant nous indiquer les réels problèmes à résoudre
et les stratégies que les technologies peuvent mettre en place.
Quand des personnes de différentes origines se rassemblent,
quand nous construisons correctement,
les possibilités sont infinies.
C'est là-dessus que je veux finir.
Moins de robots racistes, de machines qui vont nous voler nos emplois,
et plus de ce que les technologies peuvent réellement faire.
Alors oui, une partie de l'énergie dans le monde de l'IA,
des technologies,
est dirigée pour décider de quelles publicités vous sont proposées.
Mais une grosse partie est orientée pour rendre le monde meilleur.
Imaginez une femme enceinte en République Démocratique du Congo,
qui doit marcher 17 heures pour atteindre la clinique prénatale la plus proche
et avoir une consultation.
Et si elle pouvait avoir un diagnostic sur son téléphone ?
Imaginez ce que l'IA pourrait faire
pour ces 1 femmes sur 3 en Afrique du Sud
qui subissent des violences domestiques.
S'il est dangereux de dénoncer à voix haute,
elles pourraient lancer une alarme grâce à une IA,
ou avoir une aide financière et judiciaire.
Ce sont de vrais projets sur lesquels des gens, moi y compris,
travaillent en ce moment, avec l'IA.
Je suis certaine qu'il y aura dans les prochains jours,
une histoire sur le risque pour notre existence,
sur les robots nous dominant et volant nos emplois.
(Rires)
Quand quelque chose comme ça se produira,
je sais que je recevrai les mêmes messages s'inquiétant pour l'avenir.
Mais je suis très optimiste à propos de cette technologie.
C'est notre chance pour refaire de ce monde, une place égale.
Pour faire ça, nous devons la construire correctement dès le départ.
Nous avons besoin de personnes de divers genres, ethnies, sexualités et origines.
Nous avons de femmes développeurs
et pas seulement de machines embauchant les développeurs.
Il nous faut penser très soigneusement à ce que nous enseignons aux machines,
aux données que nous leur donnons,
pour qu'elles ne répètent pas nos propres erreurs.
J'espère que je vous laisse avec deux idées.
Premièrement, j'espère que vous repartirez en pensant aux biais.
Et que la prochaine fois que vous tomberez sur une publicité
supposant que vous êtes intéressé par une clinique de fertilité
ou un site de paris en ligne,
vous vous souviendrez
que ces mêmes technologies assument qu'un homme noir récidivera.
Ou qu'une femme a plus de chances d'être assistant personnel que PDG.
Et j'espère que ça vous rappellera que nous devons faire quelque chose.
Deuxièmement,
j'espère que vous vous direz
qu'il ne faut pas avoir une apparence
ou un diplôme en particulier en ingénierie ou technologie
pour créer des IA,
qui seront une force phénoménale pour l'avenir.
Inutile de ressembler à Mark Zuckerberg,
vous pouvez me ressembler.
Et c'est à vous tous, qui êtes dans cette pièce,
de convaincre les gouvernements et les sociétés
de construire des IA inclusives,
prenant en compte les minorités.
Il faut aussi que nous nous éduquions tous
sur cette technologie phénoménale.
Parce que si nous le faisons,
nous aurons à peine effleuré la surface de ce qui peut être accompli avec l'IA.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)